[Music]
on this monday night a murderous attack
police say was motivated
by hate three generations of an ontario
family
run down targeted because of their
islamic faith their hearts broke
the call is to treat it as terrorism
thousands of indigenous children
still being taken from their homes the
whole point of it is to remove you from
your community and from your culture
is foster care the modern day equivalent
of residential schools
plus a monumental movement at a canadian
university
new anxiety about adverse reactions how
the pfizer biontech shot
may affect some teenagers and the
mission to unlock a wartime mystery
think about the families the unknown
soldier who could be
canadian
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
sometimes there are no words to describe
human behavior
we begin tonight with an act of hate in
london ontario
four members of a family have been
killed in what police believe was an
intentional act
targeted because of their islamic faith
the fifth family member the youngest
a nine-year-old boy survived he's in the
hospital
police say the family was out for a walk
yesterday evening when a pickup truck
mounted the curb
hit them and kept driving
is evidence that this was a planned
premeditated
act motivated by hate
let me be clear this was an act of mass
murder perpetrated against muslims
against londoners
rooted in unspeakable hatred
a 20-year-old man has been charged with
four counts of first-degree murder and
one count of attempted murder
police say terrorism charges are also
being considered
these murders are clear evidence racism
is alive and well
in this country jeff semple has our top
story tonight
five family members were out for their
regular evening walk on sunday
in this quiet suburban neighborhood when
police say a pickup truck
sped toward them mounted the curb and
mowed them down
the pickup truck continued to drive
southbound on hyde park road at a high
rate of speed
it was observed to turn left on oxford
street
not stopping for the red light officers
eventually caught up with the truck
about seven kilometers away
and arrested the 20 year old driver
police say he was wearing
a body armor-like vest and that this was
a deliberate
planned attack we believe that this was
an intentional act
and that the victims of this horrific
incident were targeted
we believe the victims were targeted
because of their islamic faith
paige martin says she was driving nearby
when she saw the wreckage
and paramedics performing cpr i'm still
in shock
it's i am very shaken up
knowing that you know there's a kid
um multiple kids
it's just it's awful this family's just
out for a walk the victims
three generations of the same family
four
were killed the youngest a
fifteen-year-old girl
her little brother just nine years old
is now in hospital
and is expected to survive he's just
lost a grandparent
his parents and a sister once i learned
it totally you know destroyed me from
inside i can't
describe it in the words you know i even
saw them last on thursday and i can't
really come to the terms that they are
no more here like
such a nice family are nice one of the
nicest person
i can say like i have ever known this
news was
absolutely gut-wrenching and um
has shaken not just me personally but
the community to the core it's a loss of
life that is absolutely tragic
senseless and so cold-hearted
the driver had no criminal record and
london police wouldn't say why they
believe this was a targeted attack
they're now liaising with the rcmp and
deciding whether to pursue charges
of terrorism jeff semple global news
toronto
according to the latest data which is
from 2019 hate crimes in canada are on
the rise
police reported incidents increased 7
percent compared to the previous year
violent hate crimes rose by 8 percent
while there were fewer incidents
targeting
religion hate crimes against canada's
muslim population
rose by nine percent canada's last
residential school
closed in the late 1990s but thousands
of indigenous children are still being
taken from their families and
communities
according to the 2016 census 52 percent
of children in foster care across canada
were indigenous
in some provinces the ratio is much
higher in manitoba indigenous children
make up ninety percent of the nearly ten
thousand children in care
in saskatchewan it is 80 percent in a
way
foster care is an extension of the
residential school system and it's also
leading to multi-generational trauma
heather urex west reports
troy byrd was taken into canada's child
welfare system
when he was just 10 months old i went
through two foster homes
and went through a hotel system for
almost a year
the grandson of a residential school
survivor byrd believes it
is not a coincidence that so many
indigenous children
are now growing up in foster care ashley
buck agrees
the whole point of it and like of course
like you'll hear the government say like
we're trying to protect
we're trying to take care of them but
like the whole outcome and the whole
point of it is to remove you from your
community and from your culture and that
was also the point of residential
schools
bach a member of the mishki ogamong
ojibwe first nation in ontario
was taken into foster care as a baby
fostered and eventually adopted by a
white family
in bc i didn't know about this until
like uh i did a freedom of information
requests for my files
but um my bio family on my mom's side
and on my dad's side both tried to adopt
me
um and weren't for you in canada an
indigenous child
is 14 times more likely to enter the
child welfare system
the reason for that over-representation
is
poverty poor housing
caregiver substance misuse related to
mental health issues
and domestic violence related to the
multi-generational trauma
trauma that is undeniably related to the
legacy of residential schools
both bach and byrd are grandchildren of
residential school survivors
but it's not the only reason why so many
indigenous kids are being taken into
care
we need to get education early childhood
programs mental health programs
all of that stuff because that will
build a foundation for families to be
successful and for more kids to grow up
at home
i feel like it would have made a
difference while it's too late for his
childhood bird says he wants to someday
have children of his own
raised far outside the child welfare
system
surrounded by family at home heather
urex west global news calgary
in toronto a statue of the namesake of
ryerson university will
not be restored or replaced it was
defaced and pulled down on sunday
the statue of edgerton ryerson was
doused with red paint and then toppled
from its base
its head was severed taken to the harbor
and lowered
by rope into the water edgerton ryerson
is considered one of the architects
of canada's residential school system
there have been widespread calls
including from faculty and students to
go a step further and change the name of
the university
eric sorenson explains why the past is
driving these demands
for change a task force examining the
legacy of ryerson university's namesake
is to make recommendations in september
one decision
was just made for them
protesters gathered at the statue of
edgerton ryerson on sunday and then
some hauled it down 73 years after the
institution was founded
one indigenous student watched it happen
i was blown away it was very moving
and it was community who took upon it
themselves to you know
deal with the problem following the news
of children's remains found at the
residential school in kamloops
and the role ryerson himself played in
developing residential schools
the university's president declared in a
statement the statute will not be
restored or replaced
other potential changes include
consideration of the university's name
now under review by the task force he is
the architect of the residential school
system
and how harmful that is to both black
and indigenous people because of the
segregated schooling that happened here
in ontario
and across the nation the statue is gone
some university publications are also
expunging names like the ryersonian
and what could it mean for degrees
conferred in his name
it's another reason to change the
school's name altogether says this
faculty member it's very painful
for those of us who are indigenous that
are working
and going to school at ryerson to have
to have a
degree with ryerson's name on it it
needs to be changed to something much
more positive
before confederation ryerson was admired
for his vision of public school
education
but he also backed a separate education
that became a guide for the residential
school system
that tried to erase indigenous culture
canadians need to re-examine the legacy
of their historic figures
says one indigenous studies professor
people that canada has long
valued as important people in the
development of canada as a nation
were also people who were very much in
uh involved
in the colonial project and in
the subjugation of indigenous people in
canada
at ryerson university a place of honor
for the statue of its namesake has been
removed for good
the name of the university itself may
not be far behind
eric sorensen global news toronto
in ontario a man who threw a trailer
hitch from a moving car at an indigenous
woman has been sentenced
to eight years in prison barbara kentner
suffered severe internal injuries she
died six months after the attack in
january 2017.
22-year-old braden bushby was convicted
of manslaughter last year
evidence given in court revealed he was
drunk at the time
in her ruling the justice told him he
had minimized women disrespected them
and made them feel unsafe
your actions she said are an affront to
all women
cases of postpartum depression are on
the rise in canada nearly a quarter of
mothers who recently gave birth say
they're suffering
from feelings consistent with postpartum
depression and a new study reveals how
the pandemic
has made it worse jamie morocco explains
soon after heather l debs gave birth to
her firstborn son
she began to feel anxious i wasn't able
to sleep i wasn't coping
the toronto mother was diagnosed with
postpartum depression and anxiety
a battle she would have to face a second
time after having her daughter
when you experience any sort of even
mild
anxiety depression sometimes you feel
very trapped and isolated
for new parents that feeling has been
exacerbated thanks to the pandemic
a study in the canadian medical
association journal reveals between
march and november of 2020 mental health
visits during the first year after
giving birth were up
30 percent compared to pre-pandemic
that's
nine months consistently of seeing
elevated
clinical diagnoses people visiting the
doctor and getting diagnoses of
postpartum depression anxiety
psychiatrist and lead author dr simone v
god says a lack of in-person interaction
plays a large role
with the onset of all the containment we
did with the cobin 19 pandemic
people didn't have their support systems
when they had a baby and while covid may
have cut off much of our in-person
communication
it has allowed for some flexibility with
90 of health appointments now online but
egot's data revealed something experts
say
is troubling not everybody is increasing
care such as
people who are living in low income
neighborhoods dr ariel dolphin has been
at the forefront of perinatal mental
health in canada
and says the study highlights gaps in
our system she hopes are investigated
further
do they have less access to technology
and that's less
less access to virtual care
do they have less access to health care
providers
now out of her deep depression l-debs
hopes for greater awareness about the
illness
there is hope and you will get better
urging families to seek care
pandemic or not jimmy morrocker global
news toronto
new concerns about the pfizer biontech
shot coming up the potential rare side
effect in some teenagers
plus high hopes a billionaire's plan to
ride his own rocket
moderna is asking health canada to
approve its covid19 vaccine for use in
teenagers the company says
a u.s trial of 2500 youth age 12 to 17
shows the vaccine is over 93 effective
against the virus
the pfizer biotech vaccine is the only
one authorized for use in canada on
teenagers now
both companies are testing their
vaccines on children
as young as six months researchers are
studying a possible link between mrna
vaccines and an increased risk of heart
inflammation
a small number of young people mostly
teenage boys have developed the
condition after their second dose of
pfizer biontech
it is rare and a link to the vaccine has
not been proven
infectious disease experts are gathering
more data
crystal commansing reports on what is
known so far
can you tell me your birthday november
1st 2003.
as vaccinations increase in the under 18
population
a potentially new and rare adverse
reaction
medical teams are noticing some young
men ending up with inflammation around
the heart
causing chest pain and shortness of
breath myocarditis is
noted by the canadian pediatric society
as a possible
side effect of mrna vaccines canada's
top doctor teresa tam last week
said a few cases have been reported we
currently
do not see any higher rates than would
be expected in the general population
but it is somewhere something that we
need to
continuously monitor an overview of
seven
cases in healthy american males age 14
to 19 appeared in the journal pediatrics
the authors want increased awareness and
monitoring
it says all cases in this report
occurred after the second vaccine dose
fortunately none of our patients was
critically ill
and each was discharged home the
american centers for disease control
first
noted reactions in late may and launched
an investigation
very rare we've vaccinated millions of
people millions of kids
and you know this is only a small signal
a few a handful of cases that have
occurred
in the united states in israel 275
cases of myocarditis have been reported
out of roughly 5
million vaccinations israeli officials
say there is a
probable link to the pfizer biontech
vaccine
pfizer says a link has not been proven
when twelve-year-old hayden urdell went
for his shot recently
it was his grandmother a retired nurse
holding the needle
i trusted someone to get it and it makes
me safer and the people around me safer
canadian officials say they are watching
for reports of
this rare adverse reaction crystal
gamansen global news
london
alberta premier jason kenney apologized
today admitting he organized that dinner
in the sky
palace he says it was a working dinner
that didn't always follow
his own government's covet 19 rules
kenny was photographed with several
cabinet ministers and advisers on the
balcony of an edmonton building
known as the sky palace he said today
his government has to set
a higher example i thought it was
prudent
and compliant with the rules to do this
outside but it's clear that at some
points in that evening we were not all
distanced from one another by two meters
and i truly regret that
got it gutter i gotcha
still ahead a bold river rescue to save
a four-legged friend
amazon founder jeff bezos is reaching
for the stars after he steps down as ceo
later this summer
the multi-billionaire says he will ride
a blue origin rocket into space next
month
part of the first crew on board bezos
says it's been his dream to travel in
space since he was a kid
he's invited his younger brother mark to
join him
air canada says senior executives will
be giving back their bonuses
in a statement on sunday the airlines
said its president and ceo have chosen
to voluntarily return
their 2020 bonuses and share
appreciation units because of what they
call
public disappointment the statement did
not include whether middle managers
whose bonuses accounted for over 8
million dollars would be returning their
bonuses
top executives and managers were paid a
combined 10
million dollars in bonuses and last week
the finance minister called that
compensation
inappropriate air canada got a
multi-billion dollar pandemic bailout
package
from the federal government some quick
thinking kayakers in alberta have saved
a moose calf
caught in a fast-moving river hey buddy
hey
it's okay pretty cold the kayakers say
they accidentally startled the calf and
it fell into the sheep river just
outside calgary the men got out of their
kayaks grabbed a rope and pulled the
young moose across the river to safety
the calf was shaking and worn out the
kayakers believe it was just a few weeks
old
they named her mindy the moose and sent
her on her way
hopefully back to mom
next a second world war mystery is this
american war grave the resting place of
a canadian
if we could rewind 77 years we'd be
leading the newscast with the storming
of the beaches in normandy france
it was a second world war when allied
forces launched the invasion
of german-occupied western europe one
way to slow down the nazis was to
destroy their oil refineries but many
lives were lost
including a canadian air crew it's
believed their remains
were only just discovered mike armstrong
explains
commander out in great force one of the
targets for allied bombers in the second
world war
was oil refineries take one out and you
slowed down the nazi war machine
some of the most important facilities
and the most protected
were in the heart of germany that took
allied bombers
over the village of our state all these
decades later
there is a grave in the local cemetery
the tombstone reads simply
an unknown american soldier killed
in march 1945.
researcher renee schutz says that
engraving doesn't add up
shoots is with a group that studies
crash sites in central germany they
focus on one project each year
this year it's been that grave according
to witnesses
and there is one still alive the body
that was buried
was a man who jumped out of a lancaster
bomber his parachute didn't open
there are parts of that plane at the
crash site outside town
parts shoots says prove the aircraft was
a lancaster
the problem is americans didn't fly that
plane
because of the date of the crash and the
location shoots came up with a theory
he believed the body was likely canadian
well with permission from local
authorities his group dug up the grave
earlier this spring
not only did they find a complete
skeleton they also found
a box inside were more human remains
schutz believes locals collected the
remains of the rest of the crew from the
crash site
and buried them in the grave now they
also found what may be
an important clue canadian airmen wore
identity discs kind of the dog tags of
their day
while schrutz's team recovered what
appears to be a part of a disc
with three letters c a n
for canada
says it was emotional for his team
finding what may be evidence to help
prove his theory
german authorities now have the remains
and will do the initial testing
they've notified the commonwealth graves
commission but ottawa hasn't been
brought in as of yet military historian
david o'keefe says it's still
early but could be good news well if all
the evidence is there and it does
conclusively prove that this was the
aircraft this is huge
and not just for canadians and for
canadian history but think about the
families
does believe he knows which aircraft and
crew he's found
based on the location and the date there
is one that fits the bill
officially classified as lost without a
trace he's holding back
announcing which crew he thinks he's
found the men have descendants spread
out across canada
and schwartz says he wants to make sure
he's right before
they're told mike armstrong global news
montreal and that is global national for
this monday we leave you with the
growing memorial in london ontario where
four members of a family were murdered
as they went for a walk targeted police
say because they were muslim
there are no words thanks for joining us